uh first of all i think he might need to
poke lebron in the eye
a lot more you know um
to his shots like that you know i mean
but he's done it his whole career
he's done it since i've been doing them
you know hitting from
you know that type of range a big shot
put us up
three and then uh
the defense balls towards the end
knowing that you know they're down three
and
steph's gonna be the guy to probably
shoot it and we just smothered him
they do they try to make someone else
beat us um and that's the type of
defense we have to
do especially in that second half the
first half it was very
uh like the days ago and not lately
basketball
not our type of defense but we picked it
up in the second half and
just kept going we just kept playing uh
we know it's not gonna be perfect
it's a team like that but
at the end of the day we came out with
the win and that's all that matters
it's a great shot uh broken play
i sunk in thinking you know he was kind
of out of play and
they found him he got his balance just
in time and knocked him down so
um you know that's a that was a tough
one because
you don't really expect it to go in you
expect us to get the rebound come down
in transition
have a possession to uh to take the lead
but you know everything changes when it
goes in
you know all-time great players make
great shots that's what's what happens
um no different tonight but
a tough one